as a world champion muay thai woman
yeah i even figured that out you have to
have a hard time with the men i do
i bet you do i do yeah yeah because you
need to get a real one like a real real
one
like that's the only way it's gonna work
it doesn't no yeah imagine
it's hard out there for a pimp it is
right
so i had his great boyfriend
but we went out of country
we fought on the same card he fought the
day before me i fought the next day
during the fight he almost gets knocked
out
as this guy is mauling him he goes like
this
what do you think i was thinking
um not good thoughts the boyfriend the
boyfriend
my boyfriend like like this yeah you
didn't like it
no did it turn you off oh my god so much
whoa i was like dude you're getting
[ __ ] up and you're dropping you as
you're falling to the canvas you'll
still need to go [ __ ] you
like that so the way he was getting
beaten was [ __ ] with you
yeah it wasn't just that he was getting
beaten i don't care
yeah like you know like a champ or like
a like a fighter
right yeah you can't be like wow
[Laughter]
was that the beginning of the end yeah
that was and he was a great person
he was great tap tap tap tap tap yes
maybe sometimes it's like that's the
problem it's like the balance the ones
who are not going to be great boyfriends
are the ones that are going to turn you
on
i understand god the biggest
sexual organ in your body
is your brain and if you there's
something that
turns you off it turns you off it's hard
to explain now we have to go back to
why it turns you off and everything and
all that thing but it's gonna mess with
you
so that's pretty much what happened even
though he was the greatest guy it's
it there's like a blockage that happened
that made her that that turned her off i
understand where she's coming from
whether i agree or not man when you're
in your 40s you're complaining about
your dating prospects
and then you broke up with people
because they got beat up in a mixed
martial arts fight yeah
that's probably why you're single yeah
definitely definitely do you know what i
mean like
personally i just feel zero sympathy for
people who make up we want such
arbitrary reasons
you're 43 and single you struggle and
you're like what's going on i can figure
this out like
can you though at the end of the day
relationships are about compromise if
you're
willing to break up with someone over
something so frivolous as that
you deserve to be single
or knock out my [ __ ] yeah i understand
like i'm saying i think this has two
different things
her saying that and i'm like i
understand why you would say that and
why you would break up
but if you link it to her being single
i'm like
wow i figured it no that's that's where
figuring out what bothers me life says
is ups and downs and if you're going to
drop me because i had a down you didn't
like the way
i went about and lost then why would i
want you as my um on my side as a
partner
i feel like the guy who lost won yeah
you by getting rid of her
he dodged a bomb you know i mean like if
i if the bullet dodged him if i bomb
right and then i yell at the crowd
afterwards and i handle it terribly
i don't want a wife or a girlfriend
who's gonna dump me right after
rather than someone who's gonna give me
the advice i need to come back and be
better you know i mean like i want
somebody who's gonna have my back and
this girl just seems like a fair weather
fan
ironically enough right yeah when things
are great i support you the one thing
wrong deuces like and it's just crazy to
me like somebody would demand loyalty
and stuff like that they
can't yet see that they have no sense of
loyalty you know what i mean she's a
wrestling fight
a wrestling wife you know when you watch
wrestling yeah and the wrestler has a
wife or a girlfriend
and whenever he wins it's all good but
whenever he loses she goes with the
competition yeah and then it starts
that's that's her it's not like he got
beat up in a street fight that he
started
it's a mixed martial arts fight and
someone gets
knocked out their first response is what
evil turtle
or they put their hands out you have a
very natural response
to something you cannot control what it
is is that it's like if it's
he didn't really learn like he's not
to that champion thing then again he's
not in that temping
state no even the best fighters get
knocked out that way the whole handout
or turtling they all get knocked out so
this idea that you won't do this or you
won't do that they all do it
every the mightiest the mightiest guys
start turtling up
when they take a badass liver bro or
whatever so for you to sit there and be
like i can't understand you gotta be
like
most people never get knocked out like
that i'm not i'm not excusing the fact
of what she's saying i'm like i
understand
where she could come from i don't
necessarily agree with it i get it you
want to be understanding that's fine me
it's stupid
for someone in a mixed martial arts
background to be shocked
that someone gets knocked out and they
go into those kind of positions this
person is even fighting on the main card
they're fighting on the undercard so
they're not even the most high level
skilled person
you break up with a great boyfriend a
great partner
because of how they got knocked up no
swag
flip side maybe there are other things
that she's picked up on
that reflect that behavior because
rarely is it just about one thing
of course it's about an amalgamation i
agree right
she wouldn't be with an alpha dude he
gets knocked down once sec i'm out of
here nobody does that at some point if
you complain at your age you're gonna be
alone i mean
you you can't there's a bunch of my
friends that they're they're alone
and they tell me how they go about the
relationship and stuff like that and i
understand where they come from
but at the minute they're gonna be like
i'm alone and this that i'm like no
no girl no no no no no no no
no you see you're doing this that that
that that that that that that
i understand it's hard but you kind of
not can't complain it's a complaining
for me
it's the complaining yes you know but
is it not possible that this person is
just looking for reasons to break up
with somebody
it's a possibility you know what i mean
you know me like like if you're gonna
break up with somebody because you don't
like the way that they step on a leaf
right they step on the leaf you break up
with them
i'm not going to say that i can
understand that you love nature and
based off how he stepped on the leaf i'm
going to be like
you're being unreasonable you're just
looking for reasons and then for you to
sit there and be like i'm single and it
sucks
again it could be just things that added
up together
all right it could be all of that and
she just pinned it on that
the last thing a girl wants who's like a
professional
fighter or if somebody was really smart
you know yeah but even the guy's really
smart
because because then they like as long
as they ace me somewhere
yeah that [ __ ] makes no sense bro as
long as they can beat me somewhere
yeah it's self-inflicted this really is
fine you can have those ideas of what
you like and what you don't like and and
you always
find you can have that but yeah
you can't complain that the it's limited
you can't complain that it's you
who did that it's you
no you need a killer no what would
bother me about that was like
you're a fighter but you're not being a
fighter
right fighting is the action of fighting
but you you it's not because you lose
it's just you're not a
you're not a fighter anymore so mike
tyson he lost a couple of battles he's
not a fighter anymore we can't
no you lost you're not a fighter you're
not being a fighter being a fighter
doesn't equate to always winning
it's fighting it's well you're worried
that if the [ __ ] hits the fan that's
what every woman is worried
if the [ __ ] hits the fan how do you
react
how do you react and you don't really
know until you see someone react when
the [ __ ] hits the fan
and when you see the [ __ ] hitting the
fan you see them going yikes
you're like [ __ ] i can't count on you he
can't count on you either
when he's hitting the fans like you
looked at him and she hit the fan and
you're like oh you can't
i can't i can't rely on you but him
he can't rely on you because she's the
fan and he was not there to support her
so support him so
same same and you end up alone it's
pretentious
what is she is pretentious you know when
the fan
you're not going to be there but you're
not there yourself but you're righteous
in your way of
it's pretentious so that's there's a
little bit of pretension in there see i
think he would have been better outside
of the fighting situation
outside if the [ __ ] hit the fan oh so
for
me it was definitely like fighters ego
like
nah dude you need to have more pride
than that i mean people make mistakes
people panic people learn from those
mistakes i mean there are people that
fold in fights that come back way
stronger and will never fold because
they folded before they felt it
because you made a mistake you know you
you make a split second decision
in the middle of a fight and you know
when something
something inside you you you it exposes
weakness that maybe you weren't prepared
for the world to see and then when you
feel the pain of that weakness you make
a vow that you're never going to
experience that again that's entirely
possible
i feel like mental strength is not i
don't think you either have it or you
don't have it i don't buy that
i think you can develop it i think you
can build it and i think mental
toughness
and just the ability to persevere is
something that you can cultivate
let's see if she's understood it i
really believe that absolutely
absolutely so maybe he needed to feel
shying away and feel you going hey
mother
you know when you're getting hit don't
don't do any of this
to hear that so then when it's happening
they go that i'm not doing this anymore
and then they dig deep and step to the
side or clinch or just
like go out like a warrior yeah you know
or figure
your way a better better response to the
situation
then again sometimes you get clipped and
your neuromuscular system just goes
and everything's just off it's just
you're not responding right because your
your system's getting shut but it was
more like ah get away from me that's not
good
yeah i didn't like that she just ignored
everything you said
it's crazy but you know and she's stuck
on that warrior thing
yeah that that what it is to be a
fighter fair
but it's it's fine i mean yeah people
can walk they want again it just comes
down to that thing where it's like
i expect you more than from you than
what i'm willing to give myself
she listened to that whole thing that
joe said about like sometimes you come
back stronger and someone just needs to
be in your corner like no i didn't like
that she's like
yeah cool yeah yeah but he cowered it's
just interesting to me
again i understand what like separate
issues for me i'm like yeah i understand
what you're saying i understand the
dynamics and where it's from
i understand the whole yeah i get it but
then link to
being lost
it's your fault it's all you you imagine
if you were
running some kind of company goes under
you start drinking yourself to sleep
every night
because you're like just completely
depressed by it and your wife just dumps
you right then in there
so was she really loyal to you that
happens
was she loyal to you or your wealth you
know
and then you have to like the audacity
to walk around like self-righteously
like can you believe what he did no can
you believe what you did sometimes
people go through terrible things
and they don't handle it well and just
because they don't handle it well
does not mean that there's that's like
the cue for you they could be going
through something terrible
it's like the video the video that we
covered about the the girl that was with
a guy
and she dumped him and because he was
not doing good
and now he has a new girlfriend yeah and
now he's doing good yeah so now she's
pissed off
same idea yeah i'm nervous for watching
this video and just be like ugh
that's what made you dump a really good
boyfriend but hey man
everyone has the right to dump whoever
they want to dump so do your thing like
breed said
just not gonna feel bad for you at all
yeah to me it's just a thing people do
dump people for the most
dumb force shallow reasons yeah dumb
reason
and it's not like habits it's just like
in one office and the indie tell their
stories
and i'm like you're sabotaging yourself
maybe it's not it's a way of saying that
you're not ready for commitment or
whatever whatnot i don't know what it is
but that's sabotage sabotage
guaranteeing dinner down there anyway
i don't know man maybe it's because i've
been in fights so i've been knocked
and like rocked bro remember i took one
hit to like the
the liver just yes
i was crumpled and i was like this
little hits is my [ __ ]
or you ever been never been hit by in
the behind the ear
it rings you stephen hawkings it rings
you you mean
being dead no i'm at the whole
okay yeah malcolm
this is ridiculous but anyways maybe you
guys disagree maybe i'm
on this video
[Music]
foreign
you